so science writing is spectacularly
dense and it contains very specific
words it's almost always done in the
third person so we have conventions
associated with how we do the writing
right down to which verbs we use and and
the tents that we use it's very rare you
can use the first person and what that
does is it really explicitly deep
personalizes the experience the the
person the person who did it
I stirred the beaker is taken out
beakers were mixed for four hours at 450
degrees right it's as if no people were
involved this stuff just happens right
so it's a process that both condenses
the information intensifies it and D
personalizes it so it is writing but
it's a very specific style now that's
not what a reader wants who wants to
know you who wants to empathize with you
who wants to visualize themselves
participating in this sort of thing it's
not the kind of language that you use to
reach across time and distance and age
in order to talk to somebody who has
spent their hours and their days and
their their lives very very differently
and yet there should be some common
ground because what we're doing is
important people have to be able to
visualize the activity in three
dimensions they have to be able to
visualize not just the work itself but
the person doing it and I think by
sharing the stories of how it feels to
make those mistakes and how it feels to
to have those successes and and what
drives you when you fail and what drives
you when you work and there's no
progress and and how it is juggling all
the other pieces of life while you do
science I
think that gives the kind of picture
that people can realistically look at
and say I could do that or I could do
that but I wouldn't want to or I want to
do that and maybe I could do it so I
think that's the story that were obliged
to tell if we really believe that we
need more people to embrace science and
devote their lives to it I think it's
very common that scientists or technical
people have an artistic side sometimes
they are very accomplished musicians
sometimes they have very fine
tastes according to art or design and
often you know they spent a big chunk of
their childhood or they're growing up
years trying to get very good at those
activities and I would encourage people
to think of that as a latent skill maybe
that isn't called into use every day at
your job but maybe it should be maybe we
are narrowing ourselves I only say that
because I love stories I love to read
stories and I don't get to talk about my
favorite novels very often in my job and
then I wrote a science book where I
actually talked very specifically about
my favorite novels and different lines
from them that occur to me while I'm
doing science and how doing science
actually helped me figure out what these
very ambiguous quotes finally mean and I
sort of put those two things together
and I've gotten a very satisfying
response that overlapping those
interests which I always had has
resulted in something new and special
and interesting and I can't help but
think of all the artistic talent that
exists in all the scientists and
technical people that I know that is got
to be some kind of untapped resource
that could enrich everything they're
doing and I just want to incur
people to go back to that part of
themselves and and take a chance on
expressing it and and I don't know what
the hybridization is for you but I'm
pretty confident that it's worth
exploring